president Michelle I now give the floor
to the president of the European
commission Ursula on the line you have
the floor
for president metzola Dia Roberta
president Michelle
honorable members
25 years ago
the leaders of Northern Ireland Ireland
and the UK made the impossible come true
for years
every attempt to broke a piece had
failed
at Easter in 1998
when a new proposal was put on the table
the talks were once again
on the verge of collapse
it felt like Northern Ireland could
return to violence
it took the courage and the vision of
some extraordinary leaders to crush
cross the finish line
but this success was not only made at
the negotiating table in the places such
as Hillsborough Castle
at the time
outside the castle
a small crowd of school children had
gathered
with their parents
and their teachers
they came from Catholic and Protestant
families
and They Carried balloons and signs with
two simple words
peace
please
it was a stark reminder of what was at
stake in those negotiations not only
different identities ideals and
Allegiance but the future of the
children in Northern Ireland
The Good Friday Belfast agreement has
delivered on the simple demand of those
children
with 25 years of peace
25 years of possibilities
so today we celebrate Brave leaders like
John Shoon and David Trimble who came
from opposing sides and ended up sharing
a Noble Peace Prize
but we also celebrate all the peace
loving people of Ireland and Northern
Ireland the unsung heroes of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
foreign
Belfast agreement not only ended 30
years of the troubles
it also opened a new era of
cooperation
as the first line of the agreement says
it is and I quote the opportunity for a
new beginning end of quote for the two
communities and the two islands and it
was indeed a new beginning
in these 25 years
Northern Ireland has taken giant steps
forward also thanks to European support
checkpoints have been replaced with
sport venues and schools
just recently a wall was torn down in
West Belfast to make room for an EU
funded Community Center
of course many other worlds still stand
not all wounds have healed
while a peace deal can be signed with a
stroke of a pen reconciliation
is always the work of generations
but as one of Northern Ireland's
greatest Sons Van Morrison said
and I quote
for the healing
go on with the dreaming end of quote and
this is what makes the Good Friday
Belfast agreement so important
beyond the letter
and the spirit there's a promise of a
better future for all the people of
Northern Ireland
sadly
the waxed referendum raised new
challenges for both the letter and the
spirit and the promise of the goat
Friday Belfast agreement
since 2016 everyone in our reunion has
worked hard
to avoid that brexit became an obstacle
on the path of reconciliation on the
island of Ireland
this journey was never smooth
but our goal
is now finally in sight
as a set of joint Solutions under with
under the withdrawal agreement
The Winds of framework
continues to support the letter the
spirit and the promise of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
it preserves our precious single Market
it preserves Northern Ireland's integral
place in the United Kingdom's internal
Market
and crucially
it preserves the foundations of Peace by
avoiding a heart border on the island of
Ireland
and I want to thank the British prime
minister Rishi sunak for his can-do
approach
together we are staying true to the Good
Friday promise that never again will
there be a hard border on the island of
Ireland
all of this is an immense opportunity
for the people of Northern Ireland
they will have the same food on their
supermark shelves and the same access to
medicines as in the rest of the UK
and they will continue to have unique
access to the single Market that is the
most powerful driver of growth all
across our continent
everyone in Northern Ireland will
benefit from this
whether they identify as Irish British
Northern Irish European
or combination of all this
so I can only hope
that rationality will once again Prevail
like just like it did 25 years ago
honorable members thanks to the Good
Friday Belfast agreement there's a whole
generation of young people in Northern
Ireland who were born and raised in
peace
who will not accept to go back to the
problems of the fast past who just want
to live a full life
they understand better than anyone else
that peace and prosperity
were not achieved once and for all on
that Good Friday agreement a quarter of
a century ago
peace and prosperity
must be rewind day after day generation
after generation
so today
we don't just gather for commemoration
but for a new commitment
to keep working for reconciliation in
Northern Ireland in spite of all
setbacks
for the next 25 years and Way Beyond
the UK may have left our Union but peace
Remains the European promise long-live
Europe many things
thank you very much we now give the
floor